President Trump takes out in the press
the 2020 Democrats compete for attention
and radical leftists decide the problem
his guns and white people in New Zealand
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show we do have a lot to get to on
today's show a lot of breaking news
we'll get to all of it in just one
second first let me remind you that
cybercrime is something that happens to
people like you it is not just something
that happens to other people you might
think that no one wants your data or
that hackers can't grab your passwords
or credit card details but you would be
wrong a stealing data from unsuspecting
people on public Wi-Fi is one of the
simplest and cheapest ways for hackers
to make money when you leave your
internet connection unencrypted you may
as well be writing your passwords and
credit card numbers on a huge billboard
for the rest of the world to see which
is why I decided to take action to
protect myself from cyber criminals I
use expressvpn expressvpn secures and
anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address expressvpn has
easy-to-use app that runs seamlessly in
the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection that only takes one click and
using expressvpn I can successfully surf
on public Wi-Fi without being snooped on
or have my personal data stolen it cost
less than seven bucks a month and you
can get the same expressvpn protection
that I have myself protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free and expressive VPN
comm slash Ben that's expr ESS VPN comm
slash been for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressive VPN
comm slash Ben to learn more go check it
out right now alright we have a lot to
get to today first I want to thank you
all who went out and had a chance to
purchase a copy of my book the right
side of history which has soared up the
bestseller charts it is the number one
nonfiction book on planet Earth on
amazon.com outside of the health
category there's one health book that's
doing better and one fiction book that's
doing better it is number three overall
on Amazon it is the number one
nonfiction political book in the world
and so thank you for going out and
spending your hard-earned money on a
book that I think is is quite meaningful
and if you want to help us succeed buy a
couple more copies for your friends
because I think that it not only is it
good to make the New York Times make it
number one on their best seller list but
I think that also it is a worthwhile
book it's something that I think is
actually important so you can go check
that out right now all right
meanwhile when it comes to the news both
Republicans in
are sort of sitting around waiting for
the mullah report and what's shocking
about that is that there are no real
indicators that Muller's got anything
and molars so far has filed a bunch of
cases against people in Trump's orbit
for ancillary crimes there's been no
direct implication that President Trump
was directly involved in any sort of
collusion with Russia which as you'll
recall was the original purpose of the
Moller hearings in the first place well
now everyone is sort of sitting around
waiting Democrats are waiting for the
other shoe to drop Republicans are
waiting for this thing to come out so
they can move it to the backburner for
2020 and Muller is just taking his sweet
time we still don't know when this is
going to actually be released actually
at Amazon there's a placeholder date for
the release of the Mullen report the
molar reports already selling hot on
Amazon
the release date their lists March 26
but it says that's a placeholder date we
have no idea when this thing is going to
drop the Associated Press says with
Robert Muller's findings expected any
day the president has grown increasingly
confident the report will produce what
he insisted all along no clear evidence
of a conspiracy between Russia and his
2016 campaign Trump and his advisors are
considering how to weaponize those
possible findings for the 2020 race
according to current and former White
House officials and presidential
confidants who spoke on condition of
anonymity to discuss private
conversations well that's one of the
things I love it's all about how Trump
is gonna weaponize the report so he
spent two-and-a-half years investigating
what may turn out to be a giant nothing
and the question is how its Trumpkin
ties it according to members of the
press how is from gonna turn this to his
advantage
Republicans pounced much pouncing a
change is underway as well among
congressional Democrats as the AP who
have long believed the report would
offer damning evidence against the
president the Democrats are busy
building new avenue avenues for evidence
to come out opening a broad array of
investigations of trumps White House and
businesses that go far beyond Muller's
focus on Russian interference to help
Trump beat Democrat Hillary Clinton it
is a striking role reversal no one knows
exactly what Muller will say but Trump
has allies and members of Congress are
trying to map out post Pro but political
dynamics one scenario would have seemed
downright implausible
until recently says The Associated Press
the president will take the findings and
run on them rather than against them by
painting the special counsel as an
example of failed government overreach
and Trump himself as the victim who
managed to prove his innocence
Trump has been tweeting all of this
stuff out he's been tweeting out
that the Democrats house investigative
committees are a quote stone cold crazy
and you got a love president Trump on
Twitter meanwhile Adam Schiff the
chairman of the Intelligence Committee
says there's a lot more to look into and
the American people I think have
basically made up their mind here which
is that president Trump is President
Trump he's done what he's done and
nobody really cares I think virtually
all of this is baked into the cake most
of the people who spend their time
fulminating over president Trump's
supposed crimes are people who really
really dislike President Trump in the
first place everybody else keeps saying
okay where's the meat where's the beef
yeah he was surrounded by unsavory
characters he spends his entire career
surrounded by unsavory characters but
unless you can actually show me some
crimes he's committed you're gonna have
to take a back seat here Democrats
however have made promises to their base
that will largely go unfulfilled now all
of this is good for Trump you would
figure that that Trump having the upper
hand when it comes to the Mobil report
is a big win for him it takes the issue
off the table if it'll go on the other
way then this he would have had to run
against the implication that he cheated
the first time around but if the report
comes out and basically says nothing
incredibly damning about him he's going
to be able to say and rightly so that
the media have spent two full years
running high runs about how he was a
Russian tool I mean that's every Chiron
over at CNN unfortunately the president
has other agenda items that he is
worried about namely
John McCain and George Conway that's
when I spoke at the Reagan Library last
night for the book launch and it was
great thousand people showed up more
than a thousand people showed up most of
them young people and people were asking
me about president Trump's re-election
prospects and I said well the first
thing he has to do is stop saying things
like just stop your face from opening
and sounds from coming out dude because
none of this is helpful the truth is
when people think about Democrats they
don't want them in the White House and
then when people think about Trump they
generally don't want him in the White
House so if you're Trump you would
rather people think about Democrats well
the only way they're gonna do that is if
you just suck the oxygen out of the room
for the press just don't give them any
fodder don't give but that's not what
President Trump does so here as
president Trump yesterday slamming John
McCain why I mean John McCain has been
dead for six was six months and somehow
is still occupying president Trump's
headspace for free it's pretty
astonishing here's President Trump going
after John McCain
very unhappy that he didn't repeal and
replace Obamacare as you know he
campaigned on repealing in a place
replacing Obamacare for years and then
he got to a vote and he said thumbs down
and our country would have saved a
trillion dollars that we would have had
great health care so he campaigned he
told us hours before that he was going
to repeal and replace and then for some
reason I think I understand the reason
he end up going thumbs up and frankly
had we even known that I think we would
have gotten the vote because we could
have gotten somebody else so I did I
think that's disgraceful
plus there are other things I was never
a fan of John McCain and I never will be
okay so him going after John McCain
again this is just providing a headline
now is his assessment of John McCain's
behavior on Obama care correct yeah it
actually is John McCain's behavior on
Obama care was egregious he basically
killed the Republican attempt to repeal
the individual mandate and he did so at
least partially out of personal pique
with President Trump which is bad
behavior but President Trump doesn't
need to feed into this unfortunately
he's feeding into a number of storylines
that are not helpful to him he has
decided to punch back for example at
Kellyanne Conway's husband because this
is the Real Housewives over here I mean
it's just this is a reality TV show and
listen President Trump knows reality TV
so he should know that reality TV is is
not necessarily a way to gain popularity
unless you are the host and you can
preside over the over the chaos
President Trump
raised the temperature on Wednesday on
his feud with lawyer George Conway
according to the Daily Mail calling him
a quote husband from Hell for crossing
swords with him while his wife Kellyanne
serves as one of the presidents most
trusted advisors Jerry Jerry Jerry
George Conway often referred to as mr.
Kellyanne Conway by those who know him
is very jealous of his wife's success
and angry that I with her help didn't
give him the job he so desperately
wanted I barely know him but just take a
look a stone called loser and husband
from hell okay so that is a thing so the
president going after George Conway now
who is George Conway just kellyanne's
loudmouth husband who feels the
necessity to go on Twitter and sound off
a lot so what why is Trump punching town
because George Conway called him a crazy
person because George Conway has
suggested that the president's
for some narcissistic personality
disorder now here is the thing about a
narcissistic personality disorder there
are very few politicians who run for
high office who do not suffer from a
mild form of this condition narcissistic
personality disorder is basically you
are just obsessed with yourself and
think you're very important I thought
that it was true of Barack Obama people
think that it's true of President Trump
who cares and mostly why should Trump be
punching down at kellyanne's husband and
if you're Kellyanne Conway I mean I
don't even know how you make that
marriage work when you've got your boss
calling your husband a husband from hell
in that I can tell you that we have
female employees here I have not
insulted their husbands this way this is
not the way to run an administration
matter what their husbands do the
Washington Post apparently has released
a May 31st 2017 letter from Kelly on
Conway's husband to the president in
which he turned down the position of
assistant attorney general for the Civil
Division of the DOJ so Trump was
claiming that Conway was trying to get a
job with him and that turned out not to
be true it turns out that Conway
actually turned down a job from the
Trump administration he wrote at the
time Kellyanne and I continued to
support you and your administration I
look forward to doing so in whatever way
I can from outside the government that
did not obviously end up happening so
this sort of drama continues to play out
is any of this stuff useful is any of
this stuff good for President Trump of
course not of course not and now Kelly
on Conway's husband George Conway is
much more famous than he was even a week
ago Conway has said that he would
through his consideration after Trump
fired FBI director James Comey he said
I'm thinking to myself this guy's gonna
be at war with the Justice Department
for the next two years I'm not doing
this
Conway had launched a barrage of insults
at the president Monday evening tweeting
medical definitions of personality
disorders including deceitfulness and
grandiosity as symptoms and saying they
apply to the 45th president and that of
course follows on president Trump
slamming John McCain and then Saturday
Night Live over the weekend President
Trump had some extra time and just
decided to tweet from the Oval Office a
bunch of stuff a lot of it really dumb
including some nonsense about how SNL
should be federally regulated or
something and Kelly on Conway's husband
decided to jump into the fray and now
President Trump has decided to jump into
the fray if you're a Republican if
you're a conservative if you're an
American you do have to be wondering
what
is the President of the United States
thinking like you are the president dude
like this is an office that does have I
know I know we're done with decorum
I know we've decided that we don't want
that as the American people that we want
selfie stick presidents and presidents
who tweet their innermost thoughts from
the Oval Office but is this really
forwarding even your political goals I
gotta wonder in just a second we're
gonna get to a new study that shows that
trigger warnings are effectively useless
we will also get to the the Trump the
Trump attacks on the press and the press
attacking President Trump because while
Trump's attacks on Kellyanne Conway's
husband are worthless and his attacks on
McCain are counterproductive his attacks
on the press are somewhat called for
we'll talk about that in just one second
first let's talk about how you send your
packages no one really has the time to
go to the post office in fact the last
time I went to the post office I got a
96 dollar parking ticket 96 dollars
welcome to Los Angeles
who's got time for the traffic the
parking lugging all your mail and
packages it is a hassle which is why you
need stamps calm it is one of the most
popular time-saving tools for small
businesses stamps.com eliminates trips
to the post office and saves you money
with discounts you can't get even at the
post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the Postal Service direct to
your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mail box it is indeed
that simple with stamps comm you get
five cents off every first-class stamp
and up to 40% off Priority Mail not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters stamp
SATCOM is a no-brainer they save you
time and they save you money it is no
wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already used stamps calm my
listeners get a special offer right now
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage ends digital scale no long term
commitment just go to stamps calm click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage type in Shapiro that is stamps
calm enter Shapiro at the top of the
homepage for that fantastic deal stamps
comm code Shapiro alrighty so president
Trump has been expending energy on
George Conway he's been expending energy
on John McCain he's also been expending
energy on the press and here's where the
president is correct there is no
question
that the press are stacked against the
president the best case in point that I
can name is this insane story this wild
story in which CNN just won an award the
Walter Cronkite award from us he's at
Norman Lear Center announced by the USC
Annenberg School for Communication and
journalism they give an award to CNN for
what for that awful terrible 15 minutes
hate parkland town-hall shooting in
which they in which Dana lash was booed
and called a murderer in which Marco
Rubio was compared to a school shooter
CNN just won an award from USC for
journalism for that unbelievably the
Norman Lear Center titled its press
release announcing the award cronkite
award proves that facts matter it stated
CNN Parkland Town Hall a two-hour
special aired for seven only seven days
after 17 students and teachers were
murdered by a gunman at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in this compelling
and powerful forum moderator Jake Tapper
definitely gave generous space to speak
to gun control advocates politicians
parkland students parents and a
representative from the NRA the program
helps quote advance at the national
conversation on gun control and violence
the jury said I watched that thing it
was a monstrosity everybody who watched
it was made Dumber for having watched it
it was a terrible media event that media
event was specifically designed to allow
the targeting of pro-gun people and
allow really deplorable human beings
like sheriff Scott Israel of the Broward
County Police Department Sheriff's
Department to allow him to shirk his
responsibilities and blame others for
his own failures it was an egregious
egregious event and yet CNN was
championing itself winning an award for
that sort of thing because the press are
indeed incredibly biased when president
Trump's smacks the press around
sometimes it is justified now does that
mean President Trump should call the
press enemies of the people know that a
Stalinist language you should never call
people enemies of the people unless they
are actively engaged in terrorism for
example but his president from bright to
hit the press absolutely so here's the
example President Trump yesterday at the
White House he was railing against the
discrimination against conservatives
between social media censorship and fake
news he is not wrong about any of this
stuff when you get the vaccine back
office
statements made by executives of the
various companies and you see the level
of in many cases hatred they have for a
certain group of people that happen to
be in power that happened to have won
the election you say that's really
unfair so something's happening with
those groups of folks that are running
Facebook in Google and Twitter and I do
think we have to get to the bottom of it
it's very fair you know the incredible
thing is that we can win an election and
we have such a stacked deck okay well
there is truth to this he is correct
that the media have been attacking him
the media are in fact stacked to the
left there is no question that the heads
of the social media companies are to the
left now there are algorithms may not
always spit out results that are to the
left because maybe it turns out that
conservatives are kind of good at
business and that we spend a lot of time
and effort trying to figure out how we
can best reach audiences on these
platforms maybe it turns out that our
content is good and people want to
engage with it but it is true that the
social media companies have never had a
discussion about how to downplay the
traffic to huffington post they
certainly have had discussions about how
to do so to Fox News or a Daily wire
there's no when was somebody last asked
when when did someone last asked the
head of YouTube whether they ought to be
censoring material from The Young Turks
the answer is never
when did somebody who is in a prominent
position last ask whether YouTube might
think about how to change the algorithms
to censor me last week Kara Swisher did
it to the head of of YouTube so
president Trump is not wrong about the
bias in the media and it's always
astonishing to me that people on the
Left find is controversial why is it
controversial that the media are
generally biased to the left now the
media are not monolithic of course there
are many media outlets we are a
successful one here at Daily wire there
there plenty of successful right-wing
media outlets if you write all of them
and you stack them up against CBS NBC
ABC CNN The Washington Post the New York
Times the Chicago Tribune the Los
Angeles Times virtually every major
newspaper in the country does that even
play a minut role it's hard to it's hard
to suggest that right-wing media are
uneven par with with everybody else in a
left-wing media it simply is not true
even Ted Koppel acknowledged as much Ted
Koppel is no raving right winger he was
speaking at the Carnegie Endowment and
he said
listen when President Trump says the
press are out to get him they kind of
are his perception that the
establishment press is out to get him
doesn't mean the great journalism does
nothing you don't it is but the notion
that most of us look upon Donald Trump
as being an absolute Fiasco he's not
mistaken in that perception and he's not
mistaken when so many of the liberal
media for example described themselves
as belonging to the resistance
okay so Koppel is acknowledging a basic
truth good for him for at least being
honest enough to acknowledge it this is
one of the reasons people don't trust
you and then they trust MSNBC more than
they trust CNN they are not the most
trusted name in news and that is because
CNN has always hid hidden it's it's
opinions behind the facade of objective
journalism they are not objective
journalists over there and by the way
neither are the members of the the
Washington Post editorial board the
folks over at the Washington Post these
are not objective journalists either the
same people at the Washington Post
who changed the slogan of their paper to
democracy dies in darkness and slapped
it on their masthead as soon as
President Trump became president because
the press was so much under attack
yesterday they ran an op-ed from the
dictator of Turkey Recep Tayyip Erdogan
who is an Islamist who has jailed
legitimately tens of thousands of
dissenters including vast numbers of
members of the press these are the same
members of the press will claim that
President Trump is is participating in a
grave crackdown on freedom that doesn't
mean the president Trump's language with
regard to the press is good it isn't
it's not tempered it's not accurate when
the president Trump's his fake news is
the enemy of the people that would make
a little more sense if number one he
didn't use the phrase enemy of the
people and number two if he defined fake
news as made-up stories or foe of
objectivity but very often fake news to
President Trump just means something
that he doesn't like that is an
overreach with that said does President
Trump have a right to complain about
media bias in this environment he
absolutely does because the media bias
is absolutely 100 percent obvious it is
absolutely obvious and you can see how
obvious it is when you look at when you
look at for example
the the coverage and the narratives that
are driven by the Christchurch massacre
so the narrative is driven by the
Christchurch massacre on the left and
pushed by the main media have been that
white supremacy is driven by President
Trump despite the fact that the number
of white supremacist attacks in the West
over the past 10 years has fluctuated up
and down and there's no real solid
evidence that it has fluctuated up in
any permanent direction in the last two
years it was actually quite high in 2015
they've suggested President Trump is at
fault for everything they've suggested
that guns are at fault for everything I
mean these narratives are narratives
that the media are driving you can
always tell where the media stand by
whatever the topic of the news is today
there's two types of bias in the media I
think it's important to point this out
two types of bias that are worth
pointing out point of bias number one is
is the is the how you actually cover a
story so there's a shooting in New
Zealand and white supremacist terrorist
attack on a mosque in New Zealand how is
that covered what are the topics that we
talk about do we talk about the rise of
tribalism in the West do we talk about
the rise of white supremacy on its owns
we talk about for example the role of
social media as a as the first order
orange we immediately jump to this is
president Trump's fault on cable news so
we immediately jump to this is everybody
on the rights fault and anybody like Sam
Harris or Bill Maher or me who has
discussed radical Islam that those
people are somehow default for a white
supremacist shooting up a mosque even
though that white supremacist presumably
likes none of the people that I just
mentioned that's one type of bias the
other type of bias is selection bias
what the media choose to cover the media
do not choose to cover certain shootings
they do choose to cover other shootings
they'll choose to cover a mass shooting
at a school in Parkland they will not
choose to cover the shootings in Chicago
there's an obvious agenda that is
attached to that calling out media bias
is important I know people think that
it's just a way for President Trump to
deflect from the issues but if people
can't see how the narrative is being
driven by motivated people they are more
likely to believe the narrative than if
they see the motivations that undergird
the narrative that is being driven okay
in just a second I'm gonna get to a
fascinating study that suggests that
trigger warnings are a giant fail on
college campuses we'll talk about that
in just a second first let's talk about
how you can save money so we can
disagree about a wide variety of issues
and we do but there is one thing that we
should all agree on and that is let's
try to save
and that's where honey comes in honey is
great because what they do is they have
a best price finder it automatically
compares the prices of millions of
sellers they carry an item you want on
places on sites like Amazon honey even
factors in shipping sales tax Amazon
Prime status to make sure that you are
getting the lowest total price it shows
you the best deal every time even if
Amazon does not it is like having your
very own smart shopping assistant every
time I buy something on Amazon I'm
saving money and I shop on Amazon
incessantly Amazon is my jam and honey
makes it so that I am saving all sorts
of money brought some soccer equipment
for my kids I know I'm a commie
I bought some soccer equipment for my
very young children the other day from
Amazon saved some money thanks to honey
more than 10 million people are using
honey to save money honey has over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
the Google Chrome store Time magazine
says it's basically free money so next
time you're shopping on Amazon treat
yourself to the free upgrade that
guarantees you always get the absolute
best price add honey for free at join
honey calm slash Ben that is join honey
calm slash Ben honey is the smart
chopping assistant that helps you save
time and money all right so there's this
fascinating new study out today that I
think is actually more important than is
being led on it's a study that should
suggest as we all suspected that trigger
warnings are generally generally useless
so what exactly is a trigger warning if
you do not have a son or daughter in
college or if you are not a college
student yourself you probably don't know
what a trigger warning is because you
live in the real world where people say
things that offend you sometimes and
then you get over it but on college
campuses trigger warnings have become a
thing this is where you're about to
discuss a controversial topic and you
are afraid that by doing so you're going
to trigger someone's emotions and so you
are expected to issue a trigger warning
so if you are going to talk about the
issue of rape for example then you are
expected to say here's a trigger warning
to anyone who has been victimized by
rape or anybody who knows anybody who's
been victimized by rape and if you don't
issue that trigger warning you are
considered insensitive and gauche and as
though you are doing psychological
damage to somebody and this is taken to
the logical extreme at university
campuses where any controversial topic
must be accompanied by a trigger warning
lest you offend somebody
lest you might grow aggress them and if
you might grow aggress them right if you
if you say these things without a
trigger warning then you participate in
the micro aggression and that Mike
aggression is a real damage it is the
equivalent of violence is how many on
the radical left and in mainstream
academia see it now all of that is crap
it is not true a micro aggression is not
actually damaging in the same way
physical aggression is and trigger
warnings are absolutely ineffective
there's a new study it recently appeared
in clinical psychological science and it
pushes back against the findings of
Harvard University researchers who
suggested that trigger warnings might
actually be a net negative they could
make people some and some people less
resilient to trauma trigger warnings
don't really leave anyone worse off
according to a newer research conducted
by a team of researchers from the
University of Waikato and the City
University of New York but they don't
help matters either study participants
who received a trigger warning or just
as bothered by traumatic words and
images as participants who saw words and
images without any forewarning these
results suggest a trigger warning is
neither meaningfully helpful nor harmful
so we now have a study from Harvard that
says the trigger warnings are
effectively harmful because they
essentially raise your radar for stuff
that is going to offend you and now we
have a new study that says they're
useless
so trigger warnings fall somewhere
between harmful and useless on the scale
of things and yet they are the expected
mode of communication at university
campuses this study involves six
experiments at exposure to both
disturbing written materials inventing
and video clips researchers also asked
participants about their previous
experiences with traumatic episodes but
determined that trigger warnings were
effectively useless even for people with
a history of trauma so this stuff is not
only useless in many cases it's
counterproductive why because if you are
ready to be offended you're more likely
to be offended unfortunately this sort
of nonsense is now being written not
just into into campus politics it is
being written into law it's being
written into law here is the case from
from The Spectator in the UK quote here
we go again another woman is facing a
police investigation and potentially a
jail sentence because she wrote things
online about sex gender and a person who
changed gender the woman is a journalist
her name is Carolyn Farrow she's 44 and
she's the subject of an investigation by
Surrey Police over tweets she sent
referring to the adult child of Susie
green head of mermaid's a charity
concerned with transgender children
Pharos said the investigate
arises because she quote-unquote
misgendered the child who was born male
but now identifies as female pharaoh is
a columnist an occasional TV commentator
she writes and speaks with Catholic
perspectives so she's Catholic about a
number of issues including education
family policy euthanasia and gender her
political and religious stance makes a
relatively unusual among women who
question transgender orthodoxy and the
columnist for The Spectator says I point
this out here because some people are
keen to suggest anyone who challenges
the trans rights agenda is automatically
a right wing culture warrior possibly in
league with us christian conservatives
there will be there will no doubt be
those who cite pharaoh's faith as proof
of this thesis in fact i'd suggest it
proves the opposite it shows you can
find women and men who worry about
gender issues right across the political
and social spectrum pharaoh tweeted out
i'm being interviewed under caution for
misgendering susie greens daughter it's
all rather Orwellian and rather scary
the thing is i can't even remember what
i said my tweets automatically delete
after two weeks so they're investigating
me for tweets which have been deleted
but which cause offence to Susie green
she believes that she's being invested
investigated by the police for potential
malicious communications which would be
a breach of the Communications Act of
2003 section 127 of that act in Britain
relates to the improper use of public
electronic communications networks and
says a person is guilty of an offence if
he quote sends by means of a public
electronic communications network a
message or other matter that is grossly
offensive or of an indecent obscene or
medicine character or be causes any such
message or matter to be sent a person
can also offend if for purposes of
causing annoyance inconvenience or
needless anxiety to another he sends by
means of a public electronic
communication a message he knows to be
false causes such message to be sent or
persistently makes use of a public
electronic communications at Network you
could theoretically be fined or jailed
up to six months up to six months
this is absurdity the height of
absurdity in a rational society we
should be able to point out that
biological males are biological males
but apparently this is no longer a thing
and we said we say that we're making our
society better because of this they're
taking offense at basic biological
truths is making our society our society
more tolerant and more wonderful and
more accepting you're talking about
jailing your political
as folks and this is really really
dangerous stuff and yet the left
continues to push it and claim that
they're making society better nothing
could be further from the truth okay
now let's check out what's going on on
the Democratic side of the aisle so
there's a brand new CNN poll out and it
shows that there is serious movement in
the poll for really one candidate and
one candidate only that candidate would
be Kamala Harris senator Kamala Harris
she was picked up an enormous amounts of
support she's now at 12% support among
Democrats and Democratic leading
independents beta Roark is at 11%
Harris's rises across the board
according to CNN her gains her more
pronounced among Democrats she's gained
10 points among Democrats she's gained
10 points among liberals she's gained
nine points among women and she's gained
10 points among ethnic minorities and
she's pushing hard to the left so Kamala
actually came out and said last night
Connell Harris did in her quest for the
nomination that she wants to jail
President Trump that she would tried to
prosecute President Trump so we are now
back to lock him up remember when it was
really bad the president Trump was
saying lock her up and people were
chanting lock her up about Hillary
Clinton because she committed a crime
well now Kamala Harris is pledging that
you will prosecute President Trump from
crimes unspecified which is a great
thing to do it's always great when you
have a former prosecutor pledging to use
the full the full power of the executive
branch to go after somebody for a crime
that you can't even name here is Camilla
Harris pledging to do just that I also
believe that what voters are going to
want is they're gonna want that there is
someone who has the proven ability to
prosecute the case against this
administration yeah and this president
yeah
having an ability and a proven ability
to be able to articulate the evidence
that makes the case for why we need new
leadership is you're saying if you are
president and Donald Trump is out of the
White House you will then continue to
prosecute him and his various hench
characters
I am very supportive of Bob Muller being
able to finish his pasta home and do his
job okay so she she won't rule that out
she won't rule that out now I will say
that she's obviously talking about
prosecuting the case against the
president she's not talking about
prosecuting the president right now but
it's funny that she won't just say I'm
not talking about prosecuting him once
he's out of office we have to see what
kind of law breaking happens kind of
kind of fascinating obviously the
Democrats are racing to the left at the
speed of light we'll get to more of that
in just one second first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire calm and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription to daily wire when you do
you get the rest of this show live you
get two additional hours of the show
every single day and when you spend $99
you get the very greatest in beverage
vessels you left his tears hot or cold
tumblr now I desperately wish I could
drink from this hot or cold tumblr today
I cannot it is Jewish fast day sadly but
you can if you subscribe right now go
check it out right now also my latest
book the right side of history was
released yesterday if you have not yet
picked up a copy please head on over to
Amazon Barnes & Noble or right side of
history book comm and grab one well
they're still in the stores and they're
flying off the shelves right now it is
the number one nonfiction book on planet
Earth according to Amazon at least not
in the health category and today only
you can catch me doing a live book
signing on today's episode of the
conversation at 7:00 p.m. Eastern to get
a signed copy and a chance to have your
question answered head on over to
premier collectibles calm / Ben Shapiro
tune in it should be a lot of fun
if you still want to get a signed copy
of my brand-new book also when you
subscribe over at daily wire you get all
of the aforementioned wonders that we've
talked about plus you get special access
to our Sunday special our Sunday special
comes out on Saturday for you if you are
actually a subscriber our Sunday special
this week features Stephen Meyer author
of Darwin's doubt and signature in the
cell he makes the case for intelligent
design you can see what you think here's
what it sounded like hi I'm Stephen
Meyer i'm talking with ben shapiro
on the Ben Shapiro show Sundays
special and we're talking about the
theory of intelligent design God's
science in the universe okay it's really
worth a listen I think that you'll find
it fascinating whether you agree or
disagree so go check that out also make
sure that you subscribe over YouTube and
iTunes leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so with Senator Kamala Harris picking up
steam cory booker is very angry and when
cory booker is angry cory booker gets
his angry face he was doing a town hall
last night and he slammed Kamala Harris
over her laughing over her use of pot
because he was saying correctly that she
was prosecuting people for a use of pot
back when she was using it herself or
laughing about it here is what he had to
say we have presidential candidates and
Congress people and senators and now
talk about their marijuana use almost as
if it's funny but meanwhile in 2017 we
had more arrests for marijuana
possession in this country than all the
violent crime come all divine crime
arrests combined do not talk to me about
legalizing marijuana unless in the same
breath you talk to me about the
expunging the records of the millions of
people that are suffering with not being
able to find a job okay so yeah that is
not a criticism that is ill aimed he was
correct you know slamming Kamala Harris
for laughing about pot use well she was
in favor of jailing pot dealers is kind
of a fascinating take now the truth is
that Booker and and Harris are trying to
compete inside one lane of the
Democratic Party they're trying to
compete inside that intersectional Lane
of the Democratic Party and apparently
they're doing so somewhat successfully
because it turns out that right now
inside the Democratic Party Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren are not
actually gaining any sort of support
among black populations this is
according to the Washington Post quote
the crowd packed into the gym of a
century-old black church her every time
senator Bernie Sanders attacks attacked
inequities that hit disadvantaged
African Americans especially hard
applauding his ideas to address the
disparity within the disparity but the
problem Sanders faces in appealing to
black voters was staring at him as he
spoke for an hour recently at the gym of
the Royal Missionary Baptist Church of
the more than 1600 people who came to
see the candidate fewer than 40 were
black last month senator Elizabeth
Warren faced a similar dynamic in
Greenville South Carolina more than
eight hundred people filled the
community center of a politically active
Church to hear her speak but only about
a dozen black faces were visible in a
state where about 60 percent of the
Democratic electorate is
african-american Sanders in Warren chair
liberal philosophy focused on helping
those who have been hurt by the
prevailing system a message both say
resonate in black households but both
our older white candidates hailing from
New England and they often confront
skepticism if not ambivalence or
indifference from black voters who have
been noticeably absent from their
campaign events their challenges provide
a preview of hurdles likely to confront
other white candidates including former
congressman beta O'Rourke and former
Vice President Joe Biden should he join
the race
the Democratic field for the first time
includes two well-known black US
politicians both of whom are attracting
more diverse crowds and interest from
the black community a month before
Sanders spoke at Royal Missionary
Baptist Church Kamala Harris held a
rally in the same room her crowd was
much more racially varied including a
group of black women who showed up in
church hats the crowds showing up for
Senator Cory Booker also have included
far more voters of color if Sanders are
more in hope to extend their primary
campaigns beyond Iowa New Hampshire they
must find ways to forge stronger
connections with black voters
strategists from both campaigns say
privately and I wonder if that's going
to be a an actual option here now this
is the unspoken strength perhaps of Joe
Biden if you look at that CNN poll what
it shows is Joe Biden up at 28% Bernie
Sanders at 20% and then Kamala Harris at
12%
well in a democratic party that is so
divided by race it is quite possible
that somebody like Kamala Harris runs
the table in a lot of the southern
states where black voters provide a
plurality or majority of the Democratic
vote and if that's the case then Kamala
Harris has to be considered the
front-runner betting markets right now
by the way do have her as the
front-runner in this race even though in
the national polling she's only at about
12%
that's why Cory Booker is going after
Kamala Harris and that's why maybe maybe
the focus on Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders is overlooking the actual
front-runner Kamala Harris and you can
see that a lot of the more woke liberals
aren't quite upset with the fact that
the generalized polls are showing Biden
and Sanders and bado atop the pack The
Huffington Post headlined yesterday
their giant headline was the hot new
thing in the Democratic Party white men
they say last week in a profile of
Democratic presidential hopeful beta
O'Rourke
Vanity Fair reporter Joe Hagin wrote
that being a white man in a party
longing for a woman or a person of color
is perhaps her world's biggest
vulnerability NBC's Chuck Todd also
raised this possibility in an interview
with O'Rourke last weekend but the
former Texas congressman dismissed the
idea and
felice oh it's white men who are getting
an early boost in the Democratic
campaigns O'Rourke announced Monday he
had raised 6.1 million dollars for his
presidential bid in just 24 hours
the most of any of the candidates who
publicly disclosed their numbers he
narrowly beat Bernie Sanders who
announced a 5.9 million dollar haul in
his first day and polls show that the
most popular Democrat is Vice President
Joe Biden all white men at the top of
the ticket but again it is quite
possible it is quite possible that all
of this is overblown and that once the
Democratic primary starts if Camille
Harris shows any sort of serious
strength in Iowa New Hampshire then
maybe she surges out to the lead and
that's particularly true if it turns out
that for example bethe O'Rourke is is an
empty vessel if he's doing well at the
beginning but then he has exposed as the
empty vessel he is that's a problem for
him
speaking of which beta O'Rourke
continues to be hit with profiles to
demonstrate that the dude is just weird
that he's just a weird guy there's a
story in The Washington Post called the
politics of bado and Amie O'Rourke's
marriage now as I've said before I don't
really care about the marriages of
candidates I don't think they're
particularly important I don't see why
that's relevant to a person's candidacy
unless it speaks to moral character in
some way but as far as how they divide
up household duties or who works or who
doesn't that seems to me an internal
matter for the married people to decide
themselves but this Washington Post
story does underscore the idea that
baitul is kind of a weirdo and when I
say kind of a weirdo I mean he's really
a giant weirdo like there's this okay
quote he proposed on 8th on April Fool's
Day for months after they'd first met it
seemed appropriate
that's how Amy knew him then and even
now impulsive and puckish he told her on
one of their first dates that he plans
to name his first son Ulysses which they
did about a year after marrying followed
by a male and a Henry he dubbed their
dog Roosevelt before realizing that the
dog was a girl who now goes by Rosie and
then there were the pranks the
remote-controlled cockroach in the
kitchen the psychos style scares in the
shower nothing says romance quite like
popping open that curtain and
brandishing a knife for your spouse
one time according to a friend mantle
collected an especially verdant turd
from one of their kids diapers and put
it in a bowl telling Amy
it was avvocato man the Millennials are
not gonna stand for this can't read
this way with the Millennials they'll
lose their minds that's not even the
weirdest thing in this particular
profile by the way the weirdest thing in
this particular profile is that
apparently he ate dirt like really quote
whatever post defeats sadness Amy felt
they're talking about Beto's Senate race
against Ted Cruz she was able to kick
quickly she's always been the stable one
bado on the other hand more prone to
higher highs and lower lows was in a
funk in january bado hit the road much
as his father had done before him and
drew energy from the people he met and
on one stop in New Mexico he didn't
write about in his blog by eating New
Mexican dirt said to have regenerative
powers he brought some home for the
family to eat - what in the actual what
he's eating dirt mean I guess I could be
his campaign slogan peyto 2020 we love
dirt all right man so it is possible to
when the rubber hits the road for beta
O'Rourke that all of this falls apart
this is the thing for Carla Harris she
does actually have a pretty impressive
resume even if I think that her politics
really stink even though I think her
politics are completely wrong and are
really bad she does have a more
impressive resume than somebody like
Bane or orc and Bernie Sanders he is
increasingly stuck in his own in his own
lane he can't expand that way now Bernie
is is sort of running a trump campaign
circle 2016 which is I've got my base my
base is solid if everybody else did he's
up to vote I win the nomination maybe
that'll work
but Kamala Harris may continue to grow
her brand if she continues to grow if
she continues to take over not only in
the intersectional wing of the
Democratic Party but but starts to make
inroads into the mainstream wing of the
Democratic Party then Bernie Sanders
could be in some trouble because he's
not changing his ways at all in any way
I mean he's a he's a hardcore socialist
who is not going to change anytime down
the line he thinks that's gonna carry
him to victory I gotta wonder whether
he's got enough there I think the answer
is probably not I think the answer is
probably he does not have enough there
to actually get him over the finish line
unless the field just shatters and lots
of fragments Elizabeth Warren meanwhile
she continues to to throw out crazy
solutions to America's problems in the
hopes that she
we'll gain attention yesterday she
suggested we should dump the electoral
college which is the new democratic hot
thing is undermining key American
institutions like the Senate and the
electoral college here was warned
yesterday saying that it was time for
the electoral college to go to guarantee
the right to every single citizen and to
guarantee that that vote gets counted
nobody comes to Alabama in the general
presidential election or to
Massachusetts because they figure we're
not in the game because of the electoral
college so my view on this is that we
ought to get rid of the electoral
college of vote counts for everyone okay
so first of all she is just lying when
she says that people will show up in
Alabama it's a campaign if the electoral
college is no longer thing Alabama is
not populous enough people will just
skip Alabama completely the entire
campaign will take place in New York and
Boston and Los Angeles and Chicago and
Dallas all wonderful cities but the
reason for the Electoral College was
because the founders specifically wanted
there to be coalition building in
American politics they were not big fans
of the popular vote which is why every
single institution in America was
militated by a bunch of checks and
balances an Elizabeth Warren Pete but a
judge but every all the Democratic
candidates now are coming out against
the Electoral College funny they weren't
against the electoral college when they
were winning massive electoral victories
only after they lose do they start
whining about the electoral college
meanwhile Elizabeth Warren still having
trouble shaking all the questions about
her her lies about her Native American
heritage
she was asked about this on a CNN Town
Hall and she basically just said yeah my
family lied to me how do you respond to
people who think that regardless of the
underlying facts the way you handled the
question of your Native American
heritage was tone-deaf offensive and
indicative of a lack of presidential
tact I grew up in Oklahoma I learned
about my family from my family that's
just kind of who I am and I do the best
I can with it you know there was an
investigation nothing I ever did or my
family played any role in any job I ever
got so she was told about it she was
lied to by her family and that's why you
should ignore the fact that she was
lying about her heritage in official US
documents by the way there's a brand-new
poll from Emerson polling that is out
and it is very similar to that CNN poll
except that it shows Bernie Sanders and
Joe Biden running exactly even it shows
Bernie Sanders at 26 and Joe Biden at 26
so that eight-point advantage in the CNN
poll for Biden is gone it is at 26 26
according to the Emerson poem that Biden
hasn't announced yet presumably he would
get a small bump from doing so it goes
26 Sanders 26 Biden 12 Kamala Harris 11
bata O'Rourke 8 Elizabeth Warren and
then everybody else below that Pete
butter charges at 3%
good for him Andrew yang is at the same
level as Julian Castro and jay Inslee
he's got 1% so it's you know it's all up
for grabs I think Kamala Harris is the
one who's slowly but steadily building
support Bernie Sanders is banking on the
field fragmenting Joe Biden better jump
in soon and he better start with some
momentum or I think he's toast I really
do not see a great path here for Joe
Biden to win the nomination
alrighty time for some things I like and
then a thing that I hate so things that
I like today it was funny yesterday as
speaking at the Reagan Library it was a
wonderful event I mean I love the Reagan
Library it's a spectacular place
actually when I turned I believe 17 my
dad got me a jacket from the Reagan
Library for my birthday so it's an
amazing thing to be a fan of a place and
a president your entire life and then
get to speak at his Presidential Library
for the launch of your book which it was
an amazing thing
and I couldn't be more grateful to the
folks over at the Reagan Library for
organizing the event it was really
fantastic anyway i Skyped with my
daughter right before the events because
I hadn't had a chance to see her much
yesterday and she was walking around
with a book I didn't know what this book
was and then I saw what it was she was
carrying around the history of political
philosophy third edition from Leo
Strauss and Joseph cropsy I thought this
might be a little heavy for her like
physically heavy as well as
intellectually heavy it's about an
800-page book but if you enjoy my book
the right side of history and you want a
deeper dive into many of the great
philosophers that I talk about in the
right side of history this is a great
place to start a history of political
philosophy it's edited by Strauss and
cropsy not every essay is by Strauss
oral crops eats by a bunch of different
professors it really is fascinating deep
stuff it's a great resource
I highly recommend it a big fan of Leo
Strauss I'm not as much a fan of his
esoteric exoteric distinction
as I am of his kind of generalized
political philosophy he's one of the the
big believers in the sort of dichotomy
between Jerusalem and Athens and the
tension between them that I talked about
in right side of history go check it out
if you have time and if you have the
inclination history of political
philosophy from Leo Strauss and Joseph
cropsy alright time for a thing that I
hate so yesterday there's a big story in
The New York Times about how only 7
black students got into New York's most
selective high school out of 895 spots
this is a public school
it's Stuyvesant High School there 895
slots in the freshman class only 7 were
offered to black students this is
apparently a very very terrible no good
very bad thing Alexandra Cosmo Cortez
came out and she tweeted about it she
said this demonstrated the unfairness of
our public school system bill de blasio
has suggested that testing be dispensed
with
so that more black kids will get into
the school because here is the way the
school works they have an entrance exam
it's a specialized high performing
school that entrance exam determines
whether you get in or not now I guess
that the argument here is not enough
black students are getting in because of
white privilege there's only one problem
it ain't white privilege Stuyvesant High
School is 66% asian Bronx High School of
Science is 58 percent ation Brooklyn
Technical High School is 48 percent
Asian virtually every selective public
high school in New York City is
plurality or majority Asian so unless
you want to make the argument that the
system is stacked in favor of
asian-americans in the United States and
that it has nothing to do with the fact
that single motherhood in the Asian
community is exorbitantly low that Asian
families place extraordinarily high
value on education if you want to say
that the system is built for Asians by
Asians or something you're gonna have to
make that case a little bit more
apparent the fact that folks in the New
York City school system are discussing
destroying these schools in the name of
melanin levels in the name of racial
diversity without without recognizing
that what makes these schools good in
the first place is the fact that they
have admission standards that require
students to perform it's pretty
astonishing and it's again another way
for Democrats to escape responsibility
for the fact that the non elite schools
in New York City suck just as they do in
Los Angeles and in Washington DC when
you make yourself
when you make yourself subject to the
whims of teachers unions your schools
are not going to be all that great and
you've seen this at in the LAUSD system
where we keep signing bad deals with the
teachers unions and cow telling to them
so that they will pay off all of our
politicians here's how this corrupt deal
works you have to be a member of a
teachers union to teach in the LAUSD
system and then the state will actually
collect the union dues out of your
paycheck for the LAUSD for the Teachers
Federation of Teachers Union out here
and then the teachers union will take
those dues and pay off politicians with
them to make new deals with the
politicians with the union it's really
it's a deeply corrupt system there's a
good book called shadow bosses by Malory
factor that's worth reading about that
that's worth reading all about this
maybe I'll make it my own thing I like
tomorrow it is disturbing beyond all
measure that Democrats in major cities
would rather destroy the working public
high schools then build up the ones that
aren't working simply out of fealty to
unions that are putting money in their
pocket alrighty well we will be back
here later today with a couple more
hours of programming or we'll see you
here tomorrow make sure to pick up my
book the right side of history which
continues to do really well thank you so
much if you already have i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19